what about uh video games what are you
playing right
now watch dogs um love Watch Dogs Red
Dead and Madden Red Dead Redemption is
amazing um we were talking earlier about
it when you were on your horse but if
you're on Madden what's your what what's
what Squad are you picking this year I
been R I've been running with the
dolphins a lot Tyreek Tyreek kill is a
chat code right right yeah just they man
that team is like strictly speed on
offense my son murders me with Ty kill
every single time he kind of hard to
guard he's like the wide receiver Mike
so back in the day Mike Vic when he was
in
Madden Mike Vic was kind of the cheat
cod in Madden what's up
man and um I feel like Tyreek Hill this
year is the cheat code uhuh get a high
five
no high
five yeah man I miss having a
one-year-old my son's 18 my son just
turned 18 I got a little grown ass yeah
that's his favorite
word yeah yeah yeah pound it there we go
yeah you're learning your words you you
want the Hat again you can have it for a
sec it's bright though you see the
brightness oh thank you for putting the
back on my head you're so polite
thank you thank you
[Music]
okay um I wonder man like you know when
we think of like Mount Rushmore of this
rap [__] and like I told you earlier
you've you've kind
of done something that not a lot of
people have done and you've been
extremely
successful in a very shallow
business um without without being you
know kind of sticking to your your
beliefs sticking to who you are the
whole time are you kind of like
self-aware to realize that like you are
kind of you are on the Mount Rushmore of
like this hip-hop [__] that last like 10
years like you are like up there you are
the poac of Our Generation for so many
people I never seen them s so it's like
I got a long ways to
go I I don't know I just want to go into
they said and it's molded but who who's
day the industry [__] you know who the
industry is that's the
people I think so many people say it now
whether or not there are people who put
together these end of the year rap lists
and these quote unquote taste makers you
have so many people real people going to
work every day taking care of their kids
every day who say it to me that's the
[__] that matters I'll be oning a
regular job
sometime like a construction comp but I
just sit in the office every day just
all day just relax be a regular person
yeah so if you could do any sort of a
regular job it'd have be having a
construction company yeah could you ever
see yourself
like I mean retiring is that even
something you're 24 years old you have I
don't even know how many albums at this
point a lot could you ever see yourself
like does do you have thoughts about
what happens after
rap I'm kind of set on going to jail
right now so I don't think about too
much hey you want me to put you over
here when you say you're you're you're
set on going to jail what do you mean
like going back like you think that
that's just in your
fate I guess that is my
life I don't let it bother me on know
[__] like that you create the bed you
know you make the bed lay and so
you that's kind of where your head's at
when you think of the future
still that's that's interesting